[تصفيق]
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
الحيه والمباشره لثاني ايام الاقتتال
الدائر بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع تطورات عسكريه متلاحقه ووتيره
الاشتباكات في تصاعد ما دفع نقابه اطباء
السودان لمناشده المنظمات الانسانيه
الاقليميه والدوليه الى تقديم العون
والامدادات الطبيه النقابه حثت ايضا
المجتمع الدولي على الضغط لوقف الاقتتال
وحمايه المدنيين ووسط كل ذلك اعلن الجيش
السوداني سيطرته على قواعد ومقرات الدعم
السريع في سبع ولايات الجيش اضاف في بيانه
بان افراد قوات الدعم فروا من تلك المواقع
تاركين كل عتادهم ومركباتهم في المقابل
قالت قوات الدعم السريع بانها اسقطت طائره
تابعه للجيش من نوع صخوي
اذا نشدت نقابه اطباء السودان المنظمات
الانسانيه والهيئات الصحيه الدوليه
والاقليميه بتوفير الامداد الطبي لجميع
المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه في الخرطوم
ومناطق الاشتباكات في الولايات المختلفه
ونشدتهم ايضا لتامين ممرات امنه للمدنيين
والسماح بالمرور الامن لعربات الاسعاف
والكوادر الطبيه حثت ايضا المجتمع الدولي
والمنظمات الحقوقيه والدبلوماسيه على
الضغط للالزام لالزام طرفي الصراع المسلح
بوقف القتال قبل ذلك اعلنت لجنه اطباء
السودان ان عدد القتلى جراء القتال العنيف
بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ارتفع
الى 56 شخصا كما اكدت اللجنه ان استمرار
القتال بين الجانبين اسفر عن اصابه ما
يقارب
595 شخصا هذا وادعت اللجنه للوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار كما طالبت بفتح ممرات امنه
لاج العالقين والمصابين لعلاجهم
وكان قد اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته على
قواعد ومقرات للقوات الدعم السريع في سبع
ولايات وقال الجيش في بيانه ان عناصره
سيطرت على مقرات الدعم السريع في بورت
سودان كسلا الجضارف والدمازين بالاضافه
الى كوستي وكدوقلي وكذلك معسكر كرري شمال
ام درمان مضيفا ان افراد قوه الدعم فروا
من تلك المواقع تاركين كل عتادهم
من جانبها اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع انها
طائره انها اسقطت الطائره من نوع سوخوي من
دون الاشاره الى مكان سقوطها وكان بيان
سابق لقوات الدعم السريع حذر من التدخل
الاجنبي مشيرا الى ان قوات الدعم السريع
تضع تتعرض لهجوم من طيران اجنبيين في بورت
سودان شمال شرقي السودان
نشير الى هذا العاجل امامنا على الشاشه
مشاهدينا حيث تقول قوات الدعم السريع
بانها تنفي مقتل قائد قواتها في شمال وغرب
دارفور اذا قوات الدعم السريع تنفي مقتل
قائدي قواتها في شمال وغرب دارفور في
الاثناء اكد شهود عيان للعربيه عن وقوع
اشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع في
منطقه كوبر بحري في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى
استمرار الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش ومن جهته
اكد مراسل العربيه ان طيران الجيش
السوداني يقصف محيط مقر سلاح المهندسين
كما سيطر على معسكر كافوري التابع للدعم
السريع في الخرطوم ومقر اخرى للدعم السريع
في ولايه الجضارف بالاضافه الى تطوير مطار
مروي من جميع الاتجاهات
وهذا فيديو مشاهدينا تناقلته مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي قالت انه يعود لانتشار
قوات الدعم السريع للاحياء في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ومحاولات تلك القوات
استهداف طيران الجيش السوداني نتابع
[موسيقى]
من مدينه تماراويه ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار
اذا ما اخر التطورات في مجريات المعارك
حيث انت نزار
دعيني ابدا باب المعلومات التي تصل الينا
بحكم بوجودنا في هذه المنطقه ايضا وبحكم
التدفق الاخباري لابرز الاحداث التي تدور
حرب البيانات الان متواصله قبل قليل
الاعلام العسكري اعلن بانه لا صحه هكذا
نحن نقول ما ياتي عبر البيانات وعبر
الاعلام العسكري بانه لاصحه
بسقوط طائره سيخوي صباح هذا اليوم هذا ما
اكدته القوات المسلحه السودانيه عبر
الاعلام العسكري هذه النقطه النقطه
الثانيه المعلومات ايضا ترد الينا من
ولايه الشمال دارفور غربي السودان الاوضاع
هنالك محتقنه الاوضاع متازمه
اطلاق الرصاص في معظم ارجاء المدينه عبر
المدفعيه ايضا شهود عيان اكدوا لنا ذلك
معظم المواطنين الذين يقتنون في الاحياء
الغربيه انتقلوا من تلك المناطق لشده
المعارك او لشده الاشتباكات الى مناطق
اكثر امنا
الكره الان يترقب مجريات هذه العمليه في
دارفور في شرق السودان في الخرطوم اما هنا
في مروي ف حط اللحظه يشوبه الهدوء والحذر
والترقب قوات الدعم السريع ما تزال مرتكزه
داخل المطار مروي الى جانب القاعده الجويه
الجيش السوداني الان يطبق ويحاصر هذه
القاعده من اتجاهات مختلفه المواطنون الان
في حاله ترقب كما ذكرنا في حاله خوف هنالك
هدوء
يسود ويطوق مدينه
الامور الان هاديه الطرقات السالكه الجسر
الذي يربط بين مروي وكريمه لم يغلق الحركه
المستمره
يخرجون من مرويه نزار اليس كذلك
خرجوا مساء الامس عندما تنامت الى
معلوماتهم بان مسحا جويا يمكن ان ينفذ عبر
طائرات القوات الجويه السودانيه ربما
يستهدف هذه القاعده لحسم وجود قوات الدعم
السريع يتخوفون من ارتدادات هذه الهجمات
لذلك اثروا ان يخرجوا من هذه المناطق
المتاخمه للقاعده وتوجهوا صوب المناطق
الامنه منهم من عبر نهر النيل وعبر الجسر
الى منطقه كريمه وغيرها من المناطق واخرون
ظلوا في مدينه التي انقطع فيها التيار
الكهربائي لساعات طويله لكن لم يقدم الجيش
السوداني على اي طلعه عسكريه جويه الاوضاع
ما زالت على ما هي عليه منذ ان توقفت في
الساعات الاولى من صباح هذه اليوم
الاشتباكات لكن بين الفين والاخرى نهتمع
الى تبادل لاطلاق النار من هنا ومن هناك
ربما هو تمشيط ربما
هو محاوله لمغادره القاعده من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع لكن وتيره الاشتباكات
خفت لحظه التي نتحدث فيها ليس هنالك ذوي
ليس هنالك من وجود للطيران العسكري هنا
الان مباشر عمله ما يحدث في الخرطوم وهذه
الاصوات الطبيعيه التي نستمع اليها من
الخرطوم والاشتباكات والتصعيد في طلق
النار يبدو ان هناك نزار فيديو للجيش
السوداني وهو يطلق سراح ضابط من عناصر
الدعم السريع لنشاهد هذا الفيديو ابقى
معنا نزار الحمد لله على السلامه يا اخي
المتمردين
الخرج عن القانون
المسلحه يعني
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
المعسكر الاركان السريع
الله اكبر الحمد لله
ونستعين
اذا مشاهدينا يبدو ان الجيش السوداني كما
شاهدنا في هذه الصور انه يطلق سراح اللواء
الصادق سيد بعدما كان اسيرا لدى قوات
الدعم السريع منذ عشرين عشرين اذا الجيش
السوداني يطلق صراح اللواء الصادق سيد
بعدما كان اسيرا لدى قوات الدعم السريع
منذ العام 20 20
من البدايه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
معنى من القاهره اشرف العشري الكاتب
الصحفي ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام اهلا بك
معنا سيد اشرف اذا اشتباكات محتدمه في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومستمره ونسمع صوت اطلاق
النار المستمر والعنيف في العاصمه الخرطوم
ما قراءتك لما يحدث
بكل تاكيد يبدو انه من الان فصاعدا سيكون
التصويب والاهتمام وركزي الاساسيه للكلى
الطرفين لقوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع والسيد حماتي فيما يتعلق به
العاصمه الخرطوبه اعتبارها العاصمه
المركزيه من سيطر عليا يستطيع ان يصيغ
القرار السياسي ويعلن قرار الحرب او على
الاقل اعلان الانتصار من داخل خرطوم
وبالتالي يهيا له انه سيتولى مقر الامور
وسيبقى على راس البشر الثلاثه
القادمه هذا هو تصور وفكر كده الطرفين
واعتقد ان هذا الامر سيطول بدليل ان هناك
انحصار للعمليات العسكريه في بعض الاقاليم
وباتجاه نحو العاصمه الخرطوم لان هناك كل
القراءات العسكريه ومقر الجيش ومزار ومقر
القيارات الاركان ومقر ايضا مؤسسات الدوله
وبالتالي المعركه الحاسمه على ارض الواقع
علاقه الخرطوم باعتبار انها ستكون بالفعل
مسرح العمليات النهائي في من الان فصاعدا
خلال ايام القادمه ويبدو انه لا يمكن باي
حال من الاحوال التنبؤ بانه سيكون هناك
اطار زمني او خلال غدا اليوم او غدا على
عكسر تقدير العامات العسكريه
في الاراء حول قصر مداها او طول مداها او
حتى تحولها الى حرب اهليه ولكن هناك ايضا
بيانات تصدر من الجانبين كثيره جدا
ومتضاربه بشكل كبير في اي سياق يمكن وضع
هذه الكم من البيانات وهذا الكم من
التضارب فيها
بالفعل منذ العمليه بالامس فجر امس حتى
هذه اللحظه عشرات بالمئات البيانات من كلا
الطرفين كلا منهما ينسب لنفسه بعض
انتصارات والنجاحات وعمليات التطويق
والتمشيط الشامله وانه سيطر على كثير من
بعض المرافق وبعض المواقع العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه لكن يبدو مع مرور الوقت
والزمن كما حدث بالامس وحرس صباح اليوم
انه لم يحرص مثل هذا الامر تماما وان
المساله ما زالت في مساله قر وفر وان هناك
بالفعل درجه كبيره من المتضررات
والملاحقات بين فارقي النزاع سواء الجيش
سواء قوات الدعم السريع وان الجميع
الاعلام باعتبار ان من يكسب الاعلام
يحقق انتصارا نصف المعركه في هذه الحرب
واعتقد ان هذا هو المبدا الحاكم لكلا
الطرفين وبالتالي سعى الى اصدار مجموعه من
البيانات عن عمليات قتلهم الى ذلك
والتمركز وان النصر بات قريبا وانا هناك
سيطره كما فعل حمدت بالامس وقوات الدعم
السريع داخل المطار وداخل مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه داخل قصر الجمهوري
واجهزه المخابرات والاستخبارات وايضا قوات
الامن لكن كل
العملي انه لم يكن صحيحا وانها كانت مساله
تعبئه وتحشيد سياسه واعلامي من اجل كسب
الشارع السوداني وخاصه في الخرطوم العاصمه
لتحويل البوصله والوجهه باتجاه اعلان
النصر لكن اعتقد ان هذا الامر كان بعيد
المنال سيستمر مع الجميع المشهد في
السودان ربما عده ايام ما لم يكون هناك
تحرك دولي ورهان على اجتماعات الجماعه
العربيه اليوم ومجلس الامن غدا باعتبار
سيكون النقطه الفصل النهائي لوقف العمليات
اما في الحال او على الاقل اصدار قرار من
قبل مجلس الامن وليس مشهور وليس بيان
رئاسي
اجتماع
مرتقاديه طالبوا فيه على مستوى المندوبين
ماذا نتوقع من هذه الاجتماعات
بكل تاكيد اجتماع الجامعه العربيه اجتماع
مهم لانه ياتي في اطار دعوه من قبل طرفين
او دولتين رئيسيتين يشكلان جناحي الامه
العربيه ويمتلكان مقومات القوه والتاهيل
في صيغه المشهد العربي والاقليمي والبردين
لديهم درجه كبيره من الهواجس والمخاوف ان
يؤثر مثل هذا الوضع على داخل وحده سلامه
الاراضي السودانيه ويسبب كثير من الماسي
والمئالات غير المطلوبه عربيه للشعب
السوداني الفاسي مرحله دقيقه وفي ظل هذا
الظرف التاريخي الذي تعيش السودان حاليا
وبالتالي اجتماع الجماعه العربيه على درجه
كبيره من الاهميه لانه سوف يصيغ مشهد عربي
خلال الساعات القادمه اما ان يكون هناك
ادانه شامله واستنكار ورفض ممارسات ودعوه
عبر سقف زمني او تشكيل لجنه وسطاء عربيه
في الحال وتدخولها للذهاب الى الخرطوم
خلال الساعات القادمه بعد وقف اطلاق النار
او اما ان يكون هناك تعاطي معلومه المتحده
وطالب مجلس الامن بعقد جلسه التي سوف تعقد
غدا لتبني مشروع قرار واعتقد مشروع قرار
الاممي سيستند على اليه ومخرجات القناه
العربي اليوم الذي سوف يتم البناء عليه في
قرار مجلس الامن غدا باعتبار ان العالم
العربي والجماعه العربيه هي التي تستطيل
القرار المشهد العربي وبالتالي سيكون هناك
توفير حاضنه دوليه في حاله تعذر انهاء
الحرب وكنت ارى ان لدى لدى كلا الطرفين
ليست هناك رغبه في الوقف الفوري او العاجل
للمعارك على ارض الواقع لان هناك ما خوف
عديده بان يستمر هذا الوضع حتى هذا
الاسبوع وهذا ملاك
الاصوات الطبيعيه
للاشتباكات وطلق النار التي نستمع اليها
من الخرطوم مباشره حول مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني
بكل تاكيد قوات الجيش السوداني قوات
العامه العسكريه وايضا وزاره الدفاع وايضا
قصر الجمهوري يشكلوا المرتكزات الرئيسيه
وايضا الحصن الحصين لاي عمليه عسكريه من
يستطيع ان يتولى السيطره من قبل الجيش على
هذه المواقع ويعلن بحر قوات الدعم السريع
يعلن هو الفائز ثنائيه الامر خلال ايام
القادمه بانه استطاع ان يحقق النصر المبين
حسب تعبيره اما اذا استطاعت دعم السريع ان
يغير قواعد اللعبه وقواعد الاشتباك داخل
خرطوم خلال الساعات والايام القادمه اعتقد
ان هذا الامر سيؤدي الى منزلقات لا يحبط
عقباها وبالتالي سيؤدي الى تغيير قواعد
اللعبه ايضا والبحث في
وضع جديد وايضا توتر جديد داخل السودان في
مرحله القديمه لان كلا الطرفين ان يستطيع
القبول بامتصاد الطرف الاعصاب الطرف الاخر
خاصه اذا حدث النوع من التراجع والتقهكر
او الخلل او التباعد في المشهد لدى القوات
العسكريه السودانيه باعتبار القوات الجيش
الرسمي للدوله وتحمل الرمزيه الوطنيه
للشعب السوداني
المعركه ستاخذ حد من تصعيد والتباعد
الساعات القادمه هل يمكن ان يكون لمصر دول
دور فاعل في التهدئه بين الطرفين ربما
بكل تاكيد القاهره ليس فقط فيما يتعلق
بالعماد العسكريه منذ صياغه المشهد الخاص
بالمسار السياسي اشهر الماضيه كانت
القاهره تقف على مسافه قليله من كل الفرق
السودانيين
ذهبت بكثير
واعتقد زيارتهم مهمه لوزير الاستخبارات
المصري اللي هو عباس كامل
الخرطوم اكثر من مره بالاضافه ان القاره
استضافت في شهر
فبراير ما قبل الماضي ورشه عمل وطنيه
لكثير من الفرقاء والقوى السياسيه
السودانيه كان عنوانها نحو الوصول الى
صيغه تفاهم سياسي يلعب دورا كبيرا في
تسهيل توقيع او تمرير اتفاقه الاتفاق
الايطالي وبالتالي القارى لدي درجه كبيره
من الحضور في المشهد السوداني على المستوى
السياسي الاشهر الاسابيع الماضيه وترى ان
هناك رغبه مصريه
اشرف بعدم التدخل من قبل دول اوروبيه
لماذا يطلبون من القاهره عدم التدخل
في اطار التهدئه طبعا هذه اللحظه لم يتم
اعلان بشكل رسمي ربما تكون التسريبات في
هذا الشهر بالعكس
المتحده اجرت الصلاه الهدافيا مطولا
بالرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي ليله امس
رئيس السياسه الخارجيه
اجرت الصلب بوزير الخارجيه لمصر ايضا كده
في خانه ضروره ان يكون هناك تعاون بين مصر
والامم المتحده التعاون بين مصر والاتحاد
الاوروبي للوصول الى صيغه تفاهم لانقاذ
الاوضاع داخل السودان باعتبار القاهره
لاعب رئيس وجوالي في المشهد السوداني نظرا
لترابط وتوثيق وملصقات العلاقات المصريه
السودانيه بالاضافه لان القاهره تشكل حضنا
عسكريا وامنيا وسياسيا للسودان والقوه
العسكريه السودانيه والشعب السوداني
بالاضافه الى العلاقات التاريخيه الازليه
بين الشعبين المصري والسوداني بالتالي لا
يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان يقول لك طلب
بضروره ابعاد او رفع يد المصري عن التعاون
مع الاشقاء في السودان بل العكس هناك درجه
كبيره من الطلب الحظ والمطالبه والمؤازره
لتحرك مصري مع الاشقاء في العالم العربي
الدول الرئيسيه والفاعله لتوفير صيغه حل
سياسي عربي يصبوا في خانه توفير النجاح
لاي مسار سياسي قادم وقف الحرب في الحال
بعد فشل الجهور الدوليه والمسار الدولي
على مدار ثلاث سنوات حتى الان بالتالي
الكره الالف ملعب السوداني واذا توفرت
الحضاره العربيه بالتعاون مع مصر هذا
الامر يؤدي لاحداث الاختراق المطلوب خلال
الايام القادمه وليس الساعات المملكه
ستطور ابقى معي سيد اشرف لانتقل الى
الخرطوم حيث ينضم الينا رئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيار عثمان مرغني اهلا بك سيد عثمان اذن
الكره في الملعب السوداني كما يقول السيده
اشرف من في الطرف من في السودان او من من
الاطراف السودانيه يمكن ان يكون له دور في
التهدئه ربما او حتى الوساطه بين الاطراف
حاليا من الصعوبه بمكان ان يكون هناك طرف
واحد قادر على تحقيق النصابه المطلوب لان
يكون وسيط بين هذه الاطراف لكن يمكن
لمجموعات
سياسيه مجموعه احزاب او مجموعه مجموعات
قوميه
شعبيه مجتمعيه تستطيع ان تتفاهم مع
الطرفين باعتبار ان هناك خطوط اتصال
بينهما لكن
سؤال هل
تستجيب الاطراف لهذه الوصفات اتوقع ان
تكون هناك اذن صغيره الان مع هذه الاصوات
المستمره لاطلاق الرصاص ومحاولات تعديل
للوضع العسكري على الارض من الجانبين
وبوجود يعني نزعه مستمره لتحقيق التفوق
الواضح الذي يمكن ان يشير بعد ذلك الى
الوضع ميزان العمليات العسكريه كل ذلك
يجعل من صعوبه مكان في هذا التوقيت بالذات
ان يكون هناك اي قدره على الاصوات
مخططات العسكريه التي كانت اصلا مسبقا
مرتبه ستمضي الى المدى الذي يجعل هناك
خطوط واضحه بين الطرفين غالبا ستكون لصالح
الجيش طبعا ثم بعد ذلك يمكن النظر لهذه
الوصفات ليس باعتبارها وصفات انما
باعتبارها مخارج سياسيه
لاستعاده الوضع المستقر في السودان وعن اي
محاولات للوساطات واي محاولات لاستقرار
الوضع في السودان نستمع اثناء حديثنا
لاطلاق نار عنيف في الخرطوم محتدم ومتواصل
في محيط مقر قياده الجيش السوداني الان
لنستمع قليلا ابقى معي سيد عثمان
اعود اليك سيده عثمان يعني كنا نتحدث عن
اي محاولات للوساطه او التهدئه حتى ولكن
لنتحدث عن من هو الخاسر الاكبر في ظل هذه
المعارك المحتدمه سيد عثمان
نعم طبعا الخسر في المجموعه الكليه
الحصيره النهائيه لهذه المعرفه والشعب
السوداني والوطن السوداني لانه لان هذه
المعارك اولا تدور بين السودانيين الدماء
التي تسيل من الطرفين هي الدماغ السودانيه
والممتلكات وحتى
الاسلحه والذخيره التي تستخدم الان هي من
اموال سودانيه وبالتاكيد هي اموال طائله
جدا انفق الان على الحرب في هذا اليوم 24
ساعه الماضيه قد يعادل الميزانيات كانت
يمكن ان تصلح من وضع الصحه او التعليم او
غير ذلك من حجم الاموال التي صوره فيها
لكن اذا كنت تتحدثين بصوره مباشره عن
الطرفين طبعا ان الدعم السريع يعني بهذه
العمليه العسكريه سيكون هو الخاطر الاكبر
من زاويه
غير الزاويه العسكريه بحكم الفارق بين
الطرفين الفارق في ميزان القوه ايضا الدعم
السريع لم يكن مجرد مؤسسه عسكريه
سياسيه اقتصاديه
يجمع بين هذه الان بضربه واحده كلها
الدخول
لاشتباكات عنيفه في محيط مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني قبل قليل في هذه الصور المباشره
التي نراها على الشاشه
اذا اطلاق نار كثيف مشاهدينا في محيط مقر
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم واعمده الدخان تتصاعد
في سماء العاصمه كما نشاهد في الشاشه
امامنا
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيار عثمان مرغني شكرا جزيلا لك كنت
معنا من العاصمه السودانيه
انتقل الى الدكتور يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والاعلام ايضا في
العاصمه الخرطوم اهلا بك معنا دكتور اذا
كنت اتحدث مع ضيفي قبل قليل السيد عثمان
عن من هو الخاسر الاكبر في هذه المعارك
وطبعا اجاب بانهم الشعب السوداني بكل
تاكيد ولكن من المستفيد الاكبر برايك
وبحسب متابعتك دكتور
شكرا لكم وشكرا على الاتصال وتحياتي لك
وللاخوه المشاهدين
الخاسر انا اتفق مع الاستاذ عثمان الخاسر
الاكبر هو الشعب السوداني لانه كلها هؤلاء
الجيش والدعم السريع كنا ندخرهم لليوم
الاسود للاعتداء الهاشمي الذي ياتي على
البلاد من الخارج ما كنا نريد ان يصل هذا
الامر الى مرحله التقاسم فيما بينهم من
اجل الدنيا ما كنا نريد هذا الامر باي حال
من الاحوال حذرنا منه في مرات عديده عبر
الاتصال في القنوات الفضائيه وفي الصحف
كتابه ولكن ليس هنالك من يسمع اليس هنالك
من يسمع الا ضحى الغد وقد كانت هذه
الكارثه التي حدثت في الامس وفوجئ بها
الشعب السوداني وحتى قاده الجيش وقاده
الدعم جروا لهذه
المعركه لانهم كان يمكن
المقرر هو ان يجتمع في صباح ولكن هنالك من
لا يريد جهاز الامر الاتفاق والتساوي
والمصالحه الاتفاق دكتور
طبعا معروفين يعني معروف النظام الذي سقط
بثوره الشعب هو الذي يريد ان يعود على
اساس المؤسسه العسكريه وهو
اصلا المؤسسه العسكريه بانقلاب على
الديمقراطيه كانت قائمه في 89 وبالتالي لا
يريد بالسودان ان يستغرب يعني هؤلاء يمكن
ان يتحالفوا مع الشيطان من اجل ان يحقق
معارضهم وينفذ اجنداتهم ويحقق طموحاتهم
الشخصيه التي لا ترغا لان تكون طموحات وطن
هذا الوطن 30 سنه
اشعل فيه الحروف في كل بقعه من البقاع
يجر الجيش ولم يجر الدعم السريعي الى هذه
المعركه الخاسره خاسره لكل المقاييس انا
ليس فيها منتصر وليس فيها مهزوم المهزوم
والشعب السوداني
ونستمع اليه في صوت الاشتباكات المحتدمه
والمتعاليه من العاصمه استمع قليلا دكتور
الى هذه الاصوات الطبيعيه للاشتباكات
اذا اطلاق نار كثيف مشاهدينا في محيط مقر
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني كما نستمع
ونشاهد في هذه الصور المباشره لوتيره
الاشتباكات المستمره والمتصاعده والدخان
ايضا المتصاعد في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
اثر الاشتباكات بين الجيش وبين الدعم
السريع اذا تتواصل الاشتباكات العنيفه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مشاهدينا والتي
تنذر بمستوى غير مسبوق من التوتر نتابع في
هذا العرض مقارنه بين الجانبين ونتعرف
اكثر على عدد العناصر والاليات لدى كل من
القوتين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع التاسيس
الجيش السوداني تاسس في عام
1925 قوات الدعم السريع تاسست في اغسطس
2013 التعداد العسكريه الجيش السوداني
يبلغ نحو ربع مليون جندي قوات الدعم تقدر
بنحو 100 الف مقاتل الترسانه العسكريه
الجويه الجيش السوداني لديه 191 طائره
حربيه
45 مقاتله 37 طائره هجوميه وخمس وعشرون
طائره شحن عسكريه قوات الدعم لا تمتلك اي
طائرات
الترسانه العسكريه البريه الجيش السوداني
يمتلك 20 منصه صواريخ
270 دبابه
403 مدرعات سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه
قوات الدعم لديها اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه
عشره الاف سياره رباعيه الدفع الجيش
السوداني يحتل المرتبه 75 عالميا في قائمه
اقوى جيوش العالم
[موسيقى]
ونشر الجيش السوداني شريطا مصورا يظهر
سيطره قوته على مقر لقوات الدعم السريع في
ولايه الجضارف شرقي السودان
واظهرت مقاطع مصوره اخرى لاشتباكات
بالدبابات بين قوات الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في احد الطرق الرئيسيه في الخرطوم
طيب اذا نعود الى القاهره
والدكتور او السيد اشرف العشري الكاتب
الصحفي ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام سيد
اشرف يعني كنت اتحدث انا مع ضيفي من
الخرطوم بان هناك اطراف لا تود الاستقرار
للسودان لا ترغب في ان ترى الامن يسود
والوضع السياسي يستتب برايك هل يمكن ان
يكون هناك اطراف خارجيه لها ذات الرغبات
بعدم استقرار السودان
بكل تاكيد هناك كما هناك اطراف داخليه
ومحسوبه على حسب المؤتمر الشعبي الحزب
الحاكم الذي حكم السودان في عهد البشير
الثلاثين عاما هناك ايضا اطراف خارجيه
لديها درجه كبيره من حشر السودان في
الزاويه واعتقد ان العلاقات مع اثيوبيا
علاقات متاذيبه في المقام الاول وايضا مع
كثير الدول الكبار في الشرق افريقيا لديها
درجه كبيره من احداث نوع من استمرار قلاقل
في السودان بالاضافه لان الشعب القياده
السودانيه في المدار الثلاث سنوات الماضيه
لم تسعى لبناء علاقات على الاقل بكثير من
العلاقات فيها نديه مع كاسين بعض الدول
التي تعاند او ولديها مواقف عدائيه باتجاه
السودان وبالتالي في مرحله الامكانيه ان
يكون هناك درجه كبيره من الخسران واحداث
نوع من التلاهي او الالتهاء في المشاكل
الداخليه السودانيه وعلى امل ان يكون هناك
بالفعل درجه كبيره من تكريس لوضع قائم كما
حدث في عزبه مياه النيل على سبيل المثال
بين السودان وبين مصر من ناحيه ومع الجانب
الاثيوبي في المقابل ايضا هناك الحدوديه
حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت قائمه في منطقه
شرق افريقيا بين السودان واثيوبيا وغيرها
من بعض دول الجوار الافريقي بالاضافه لان
هناك بالفعل درجه كبيره من فشل زريع للاسف
الشديد من قبل الاتحاد الافريقي ومن قبل
ايضا الامم المتحده والمجتمع الدولي في
ضروره توفير حقوق استحقاقات الحل العاجل
على مدار ثلاث سنوات فيما يتعلق بدوره
توصل الى الاطار الاتفاق الايطالي او على
الاقل اتفاق سلام ينهي كافه هذه التحديات
الموجوده داخل السودان وان كنت ارى ان
القياده السودانيه تتحمل جزء من هذه من
هذه المعضله خاصه واننا نؤكد ان ما حدث
اليوم ويحدث بالامس واليوم ليس ولدي
اللحظه اعتقد انه نتيجه تراكمات وانه لا
يمكن انه تم تخطيط له من قبل السيد حميد
والدعم السريع بين عشيه وضحاها اعتقد
الامر استغرق عده اسابيع بحجم بدليل ان
هناك استهدافات لتمركز وتماضع الاهداف
استراتيجيه داخل الخرطوم وفي بعض الاقاليم
السودانيه واعتقد ان هذا الامر كان مخطط
له بعنايه وان هناك اهداف تم رصدها وقررت
تعاطي معها من قبل تعاطي معهم قبل الدعم
السريع في محاوله تدقيق الخناق وحشر الجيش
في الزاويه
واحداثود
القوات المسلحه السودانيه تقول في هذا
العاجل الذي وردنا بان الاشتباكات لا تزال
دائره لكن الموقف يتجه الى الاستقرار يعني
هل بالفعل يمكن ان نقول اليوم في اليوم
الثاني من الاشتباكات بان الموقف يتجه الى
الاستقرار بهذه السرعه سيد اشرف
بين التمنيات وبين الواقعه على الارض
وقائع العمليه العسكريه وجغرافيا نزال
العسكري والمنازله العسكريه تؤكد ان
المساله سوف تطول عده ايام لانه يبدو انك
تحشيد عسكري وعده وعتاد لدى كلا الجانبين
وان
الحشد الشعبي لم يذهب لهذه المعركه دون ان
يكون لديه سقف وغطاء وحاضنه عسكريه من
داخله داخل قواته 100 الف او على الاقل
خمسين الف سيلعبون دورا كبيرا في تشتيت
المشهد العسكري داخل السودان ليس فقط في
الخرطوم لكن في اكثر من ساحه وعلى اكثر من
مسرح وبالتالي نرى او نتمنى ان يكون وقفا
عاجلا لكن اعتقد ان الواقعه تشير الى ان
تشير الى ان هناك استمرار لهذه العمليه ما
لم يكن هناك قرار وعربي باستمرار في هذه
العمليه سيد اشرف ابقى معي نشير الى هذه
الصور المباشره مشاهدينا للدخان المتصاعد
في سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اثر
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وبين الدعم السريع
طبعا هذه اعمده الدخان هذه نراها في محيط
مقر قياده الجيش السوداني مباشره على
الصور امامنا واطلاق نار كثيف في المحيط
القاعده لنستمع
[موسيقى]
اذا نستمع مشاهدينا الى اصوات طبيعيه
ومباشره من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ونشاهد ايضا اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من محيط
مقر قياده الجيش السوداني اثراء تصاعد
الاشتباكات وتصاعد وتيره اطلاق النار بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في هذا الصراع بينهم
والذي يقول الخبراء والمتابعين بانه صراع
ازلي وقديم وليس وليد اللحظه
وكان قد نشر الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا
شريطا مصورا يظهر سيطره قواته على مقر
لقوات الدعم السريع في ولايه الجضارف شرقي
السودان
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واظهرت مقاطع مصوره الاشتباكات بالدبابات
بين قوات الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في
احد الطرق الرئيسيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
السلام
وقف وقف وقف وقف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سريع
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
ايوه الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعلى الصعيد السياسي فبحسب تغريده لسفير
الولايات المتحده لدى جمهوريه السودان جون
جود فيري عبر اعضاء مجلس الامن عن اسفهم
للخسائر في الارواح والجرحى وحتى الاعضاء
في بيان حتى الاطراف على الوقف الفوري
للاعمال القتاليه ودعوا جميع الاطراف الى
العوده الى الحوار لحل الازمه الحاليه في
السودان كما شددوا على اهميه الحفاظ على
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه وضمان سلامه
ممثلي الامم المتحده
وعربت الخارجيه الصينيه عن قلقها البالغ
حياله تطورات الوضع الامني في السودان كما
دعا الطرفي الصراع لوقف اطلاق النار لمنع
تصعيد الموقف ومن جهتها اكدت سفاره الصين
في السودان انها لم تتلقى اي تقارير عن
سقوط صينيين جراء الاوضاع الامنيه في
السودان وفقا لما نقلته وسائل اعلام صينيه
واثارت الاحداث الجاريه في السودان
استنكار الشارع العربي لنشاهد احنا
بنستنكر السودان يعني شعب الله يكون بعونه
شعب مسكين الطيب الله يكون بعونهم يعني
اللي بصير فيهم هذا والله حرام يعني
الدنيا داخله على عيد والله يكون بعونهم
يا رب بصراحه اللي بيحدث حاليا في السودان
اكيد ما في حدا عربي او مسلم بيرضى في هيك
وضع بصير احنا الشعب السوداني شعب شقيق
شعب عربي مسلم ما في حدا منا اكيد بيرضى
اللي بصير فيه احنا بنستنكر الفسير في
السودان عشان السودان اخوتنا واحنا كنا
بلد واحد بلد عربي
شيء مؤسف اللي عم يصير بالسودان بس يعني
بالمجمل نحن اكيد مع كل شيء اسمه شرعيه
ومع الجيش ودود اي انقلاب اي دوله عربيه
حرام اي دوله عربيه يصير فيها انقلاب امني
اول شيء الشعب السوداني شعب معطر الحرام
اللي عم يصير فيها هيك السودان بلاك بلد
شقيق بلد عربي واللي بيحصل ده طبعا صعب
جدا وفي مشكله كلمه للشعب السوداني ان هم
يصمدوا ويكونوا ايد واحده مع بعضيهم لان
اللي بيحصل دون بيفرج العالم كله عليهم
التكالب على السلطه وفرض الراي مش هيوصل
السودان الا في الحديد وبلاش موضوع
الانقلابات والحاجات الديه لان دي عماله
تضيع في وقت كبير جدا وبتستهلك ثروات
السودان واقتصاد السودان
وعلى صعيد ردود الفعل الدوليه على ما يحدث
في السودان مشاهدينا الخارجيه البريطانيه
تقول بانه يجب على القاده السودانيين خفض
التصعيد وتفادي سفك مزيد من الدماء وينضم
الينا من مدينه مروي مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار نتابع معك صور مباشره من
الخرطوم ولكن نتحدث اليك من مروين وهذه
اصوات طبيعيه للاشتباكات والتصعيد المستمر
واعمده الدخان المتصاعده في سماء الخرقوم
كذلك نشاهدنا نشاهدها على الشاشه امامنا
نزار ما الجديد حول وضع الجيش الذي يحاصر
الدعم السريع في القاعده وفي المطار وكيف
هو وضع الجنود المصريين كذلك في الداخل هل
من جديد
[موسيقى]
ليس هنالك الان اشتباكات خلال ثلاث ساعات
صباحا من هذه الساعه كنا نستمع الى بعض
الرشاقات لاعي ناريه من محيط الجيش او من
محيط هذه القاعده قاعده مرويه الجويه لكن
الان سبطت تماما اصوات البنادق الصمت هو
فقط من يسيطر على الاجواء في مدينه مروي
القوات القوات الجيش السوداني ما زالت في
مواقعها متمركزه في محيط قاعده مروي
الجويه تحيط بهذه القاعده قوات الدعم
السريع مما زالت داخل هذه القاعده
هذه هي الوضعيه التي كانت منذ يوم امس وما
زالت مستمره الاشتباكات الان متوقفه حاله
الهدوء الان تسود في المدينه
المواطنون الان في منازلهم هنالك
في حاله حظر التجوال فرضت قصريا على
المواطنين لذلك هم يتخلصون من الخروج
لا هي فرضت بصوره اليه الجيش لم يعلن حاله
الطوارئ لذه امن الولايه الشماليه لم تعلن
حاله الطوارئ تم فقط اعطاء عطله او اجازه
للمدارس هنا في الولايه الشماليه مدارس
الاساس والمدارس الثانويه تمهيدا لعطله
عيد الفطر المبارك المقبل لكن الان
الاجواء في مدينه مروي هي الان هاديه لا
وجود لاي حشد او تحشيد او مركبات تجول
وتتحرك في صدى وشوارح هذه المدينه الكره
الان في منزله يتابع عبر التلفاز يتابع
عبر الاعلام عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كيف ستمضي الامور خاصه وهم يدركون ويعلمون
ان ما حدث يوم الامس في مروي وما سيحدث
يمكن ان يعيد الاجواء الاجواء الحرب
واجواء الرصاص مره اخرى لانهم يدركون
ويعرفون بان هنا لقوات تتبع لدعم السريع
ما زالت في مدينه مروي في القاعده
ما زالت في مدينه مروي هذا يعطي مؤشر واضح
بان الاشتباكات ستحدث لكن متى هذا هو
الفيصل لذلك حاله التوتر هي التي تسيطر
وهي التي تسود الاجواء الان طيب نزار يعني
ما الانباء الوارده لديك عن المناطق
الاخرى التي تشهد اشتباكات مثل العاصمه
ربما والتي نسمع مباشره اصوات الاشتباكات
وطلق الناري ونرى ايضا اعمده الدخان
المتصاعده في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ويتصاعد بكثافه كذلك
نعم خريطه للاشتباكات
الجغرافيا تمددت منذ الامس عندما كانت في
الخرطومه العاصمه امتدت شمالا الى مروي
هنا في شمال السودان الان يمكن ان نحدث
اخباريا ونقول بان الشمال دارفور في الجزء
الغربي من السودان ايضا دخلت بقوه في خط
هذه المواجهات العسكريه المواطنون عبر
الشهود اعيان وابرم معلومات مؤكده قالوا
وذكروا بان حاله الهلع والرعب هي التي
تسيطر على المدينه
يستمعوا وما زالوا يستمعون الى صوت
المدفعيه الثقيله الى صوت الراديمات الى
صوت الاسلحه داخل مدينه الفاشر معظم
الاحياء الغربيه الان تتجه نحو وسط
المدينه والى خارج المدينه ربما في حاله
نزوح فرضت عليهم خلال الساعات الماضيه
هنالك مناشدات من منظمات المجتمع المدني
هنالك مناسبات من اعيان دارفور شمال
دارفور بضروره خفض التضعيد وان مراعاه
الابرياء والعزل في هذه المناطق في شرق
السودان ايضا في مدينه القضارف الوضع ايضا
يشهد سخونه في شمال السودان كما ذكرنا هنا
في مروي في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
بيانات الجيش تؤكد بيانات الدعم السريع
ايضا تؤكد حرب البيانات ما زالت مشتعله
على سبيل المثال ما يذكره الدعم السريع
باسقاط طائره سيخوي مباشره يرد الاعلام
العسكري بانه لاصحه لما يصفها بالادعاء
بسقوط طائرات الصخور اذا هي حرب بكل
معناها هذه الكلمه البيانات ردود الفعل
بالتالي الان المسار مفتوح العمليه مستمره
كل دقيقه كل ساعه سنشهد تطورات ونشهد
معلومات ونشهد تحديثات ومعطيات لما يدور
على ارض الواقع سواء هنا في مروي او في
الخرطوم او في دارفور او في غرب السودان
او في شرق السودان واضح ابقى مع نزار
لانقل الى القاهره والسفير الدكتور صلاح
حليمه رئيس مكتب الجامعه العربيه
في السودان سابقا ولكن قبل ذلك
لنشير الى ان بريطانيا مشاهدينا اعربت عن
اسفها لسقوط ضحايا في السودان بسبب عمليات
العنف الاخيره مطالبه بوقف العنف بشكل
فوري ودعت الخارجيه البريطانيه ايضا في
بيان لها قوات الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع الى وقف جميع العمليات القتاليه
وان تعمل القياده على
التهدئه وخفض التصعيد ومنع وقوع مزيد من
الضحايا والعوده الى الحوار لحل الخلافات
الى القاهره مشاهدينا حيث انضم الينا
الدكتور صلاح حليمه رئيس مكتب الجامعه
العربيه في السودان سابقا اهلا بك معنا
دكتور صلاح برايك وبحسب متابعتك لما يحدث
من تطورات ومعارك في السودان على ماذا
يقتتلون الاطراف هل هو صراع شخصي وحقد
دفين كما يرى البعض ام انه صراع وجودي
لهذا الحزب او ذاك او هذه الجهه او تلك ام
انه هذه الجهه تحارب من اجل ذلك والاخرى
من اجل شيء اخر
واقع الامر ما تفضلت به هو امر وارد
يضاف اليه انه صراع بالقطع على السلطه
والمركز والنفوز خاصه في اطار الاتفاق
الايطالي حيث ما تم
البحث في هذا الاطار وضع
القوات الدعم الوضعيه
ذات
استقلاليه عن المقوات المسلحه وهو امر في
واقع الامر لم يعطى بقبول بجانب قياده
الجيش السوداني لان في
المطالبه بفتره زمنيه عشر سنوات اعتقد هي
فتره طويله وربما يكون فيها نوع من
الاستقلاليه والاتاحه الفرصه
اكثر
عديده ليس فقط الصراع الشخصي وليس فقط
المركز والنفوز وانما ايضا صراع على
الوجود عندما تحول الامر الى صراع بالسلاح
بين الجانبين
بين الجانبين دكتور وهذه اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد بشكل كثيف جدا في سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم كما نتابع في الصور المباشره التي
تريدنا من هناك وايضا بين الحين والاخر
نستمع الى اطلاق نار واشتباكات بوتيره
متصاعده في العاصمه حول محيط مقر قياده
الجيش السوداني لنستمع قليلا
ايضا على الصعيد او على صعيد ردود الفعل
الدوليه التي ترد تباعا حول ما يحدث في
السودان مشاهدينا وزير خارجيه ايطاليا
يدعو الى انهاء الاعمال العدائيه في
السودان واللجوء الى الحوار وقبل قليل
السفير الروسي في الخرطوم قال بان الجيش
السوداني لا يرغب في التفاوض مع الدعم
السريع دكتور صلاح اعود اليك لماذا قد لا
يرغب
الجيش السوداني في التفاوض مع الدعم
السريع بحسب السفير الروسي في الخرطوم مع
انه قبل ان ان تنفجر هذه المعركه وهذا
الاحتلام بين الجانبين كان هناك دعوات
للتهدئه وكان هناك محاولات للحوار
الجيش السوداني
للتحركات التي بداها الدعم السريع من
الناحيه القانونيه هو التبرد ايضا هو من
الناحيه
السياسيه هو انقلاب على المكون داخل
المكون العسكري ومن ثم ساصبح هناك صراع
بين الجانبين في هذا الاطار القانوني
والسياسي لا شك ايضا ان ما دار في اطار
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري كان مدعاه
لتحقيق
على التحرك والانتصار في كافه مناطق
الصومال في قصه مناطق السودان وتجهت
بالدرجه الاولى الى منطقه مروي وهذا امر
يجب ان نرسله ونركز عليه ثم جاء رد الفعل
من جانب القوات المسلحه تطالبها بالعوده
الى مكانها وعدم انتشار خاصه انه تم بدون
اذن وبدون تنسيق مسبق من جانب قياده
القوات المسلحه المفترض ان قياده القيام
السريه سيتباعها وتنفق معها في اي تحركات
من ثم في ان السودان اصبح صدام حتنيا
وصراعا بقوه السلاح رغم الجهود والمحاولات
التي تفضل من كافه اطراف اعضاء المجتمع
الدولي سواء كانت الاليه الثلاثيه او
الرباعيه او سواء كان من جانب قوه دوليه
تهتم بشان السوداني مثل روسيا والصين
وغيره ما سواء ايضا
الجامعه العربيه ومن جانب مصر في تحرك
يجري حاليا في اطار الجامعه العربيه وايضا
في اطار الثنائي من ج في هذا المجال طيب
دكتور متى يمكن ان نقول بان هذه اللحظه هل
هذه اللحظه قد حسمت المعركه وهنا وجبت
تدخل الاممي وجب التدخل الدولي وجب التدخل
لاطراف خارجيه ربما تساهم في تهدئه الوضع
الداخلي
انا اعتقد
امر يعني يستغرق وقتا طويلا بحكم طبيعه
مثل هذه المعارك في داخل المدن الى نهايه
تتميز
ورغم ما يبدو وضوحا من خلال البيانات
الصادره من الجانبين ان الجانب الخاص
بالقوات المسلحه ربما
الى ترجيح كفته رغم ما يقال حاليا ايضا من
واقع ما تتحرك فيه القوات الدعم السريع
اذا من فتره التقطي تقديري تطول ايام لكن
نامت الدور الخاص اقتنع الدولي والقوه في
القوى والاحزاب والاطياف السياسيه في
استهلال المحليه تدفع في محاوله على الاقل
لوقت اطلاق النار
نعم شكرا
ايضا في هذا الاتجاه ليكون لهم دورا في
اطار الاليه الثلاثيه شكرا لك من القاهره
السفير الدكتور صلاح حليمه رئيس مكتب
الجامعه العربيه في السودان سابقا اذا
مشاهدينا نشير الى هذا العاجل الذي يقول
فيه السفيره الروسيه في الخرطوم ان الجيش
السوداني لا يرغب في التفاوض مع الدعم
السريع وهذه ايضا امامنا صور مباشره
لعمدات الدخان المتصاعده في سماء الخرطوم
اثرى الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع واصوات
لاطلاق النار وتبادل رشقات اطلاق النار
والتصعيد المستمر الذي نراه ونستمع له في
العاصمه الخرطيه
اذا اطلاق نار كثيف مشاهدينا في محيط مقر
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني واصوات
لاطلاق واطلاق مدفعيات على ما يبدو بحسب
الاصوات التي نستمع اليها وحجم الدخان
المتصاعد في سماء العاصمه ننتقل الى مروي
وحيث ينضم الينا مجددا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي اجدد ترحيبي بك نزار اذا يعني
السفير الروسي في السودان يقول بان الجيش
لا يرغب في الحوار مع الدعم السريع على اي
اساس اطلق هذه التصريحات هل من اشارات هل
من تصريحات خرجت من جانب الجيش تشير الى
ذلك
يعني المتتبع لسياقات هذه الازمه منذ ان
بدات منذ ان دخلت الى هذه المرحله والى
هذا الثوره التصعيدي
بيانات الجيش السوداني
عندما صدرت عندما يعني تفاعلت هذه الازمه
قبل خمسه ايام ووصول هذه القوات قوات
الدعم السريعي الى قاعده مروي العسكريه
الجويه كان الحديث حول ضروره ان تلتزم هذه
القوات
بمنهجيه القوات المسلحه وان تنفق مع الجيش
السوداني في كل هذه التحركات بعدها بدات
مباشره الحرب البيانات والبيانات المضاده
وبان الجيش السوداني ليس بمقدوره ان
يتعامل مع قوات تنتهي مثل هذا النهج ربما
فهمت هذه الاشارات من قبل عفوا من قبل
الفاعلين الدوليين وتحديدا هنا روسيا بان
الجيش لا يرغب ولكن مثل هذه التصريحات
يمكن ان تكون مبدئيه ولا يمكن ان نؤكد
عليها على العموم من يرد على مثل هذه
التصريحات هو الجيش السوري يعني هل هو على
يجلس ويتفاوض في ظل هذه الظروف ولكن ما
نلاحظه الان
بان تصريحات الجيش هي الان على الارض عبر
عمليه عسكريه يقول بانه يريد ان
يضع الامن على اولويته وان يستقر الوضع
وان يقوم بكل ما يلزم لاعاده الامور الى
الى نصابها هذا ما يفهم
عن الوضع الانساني للسكان والمتضررين
والمصابين يعني قرابه 600 مصاب حتى الان
اثر الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
باختصار كيف هي اوضاعهم
هذه الحرب حرب الان وكانها حرب الشوارع
خلفت الضحايا لان التحركات تحركات الطيران
تحركات المدرعات تحركات الاليات العسكريه
هي داخل المدن مدن المدن الثلاثه سواء كان
العاصمه الخرطوم او ام درمان او الخرطوم
بحري او محلي الشرق النيل هذه مدن مرتضى
بالسكان فيها شوارع اي تحركات لاليات
لطائرات بالتاكيد ستتسبب في خسائر الارواح
وفي الممتلكات وهذا ما دفع
عديدات والمنظمات والاصوات والاعلاميين
بضروره ان يتم خفض التضعيف وان ينقل
المدنيون بانفسهم عن اي مصدر من مصادر
النيران
من مروي
التغطيه مستمره مشاهدينا في استوديوهاتنا
في دبي والزميل ابراهيم بدر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات